we will concede we have spent many happy
years making fun of Mr Don Lamont of CNN
and at times we'll concede we've been a
little cruel
but isn't as we have mocked him and we
have there has been honestly an
undercurrent of real affection we kind
of admired Don Lemon how can a man so
obviously limited have such boundless
self-esteem doesn't he know he's an
idiot no he has no idea this is the guy
who once suggested that a commercial
airliner had been eaten by a black hole
and when people laughed at him he seemed
completely unbothered by their laughter
in a world of intellectual pretense Don
Lemon is not ashamed of being dumb or
for that matter ashamed of anything else
when he got fired last year from his
prime time gig for low ratings and
reassigned to mornings he told viewers
it was a promotion and he seemed to mean
it
so whatever else you say about Mr Don
Lamont he is unflappable
or so we assumed it turns out there is
in fact one thing that bothers Don
Lamont and that's not being the
prettiest person on the set that drives
him insane
so possibly as a kind of torture a kind
of punishment CNN's new president Chris
Licht paired Don Lemon with two much
younger much more attractive co-hosts
Caitlin Collins and Poppy Harlow
and the normally Steely Dan Leman began
to melt down before her very eyes the
other day for example after Caitlyn
Collins interviewed a republican member
of Congress Don Lemon launched into an
attack on Republicans that wasn't
actually an attack on Republicans but a
not so veiled attack on his co-host
Caitlin Collins
can't do that producers in the control
room turned up the music to get him to
be quiet we're going to commercial now
but he shushed them to keep attacking
her watch this thank you for taking time
to join us thank you for having me
all right thank you that's going to be
it that's the time that we're in where
facts are sort of flexible
and why we got Caitlyn Collins on the
hill things out there checking in real
time it was a great interview exciting
incredible sources like citing the New
York Post is a credible source and
saying that facts are it's just I can't
believe that we're here Caitlin that was
a great interview All Right Moving On
um anyway well now moving on because
that's listen
that's a big issue when it comes to the
American hold on please with the music
American people the American people are
going to have to suffer through all of
this stuff from election deniers to
people who don't believe in facts we
don't have a shared reality and now it's
taken center stage two people like
Marjory Taylor green
this is thanks
alcoholic passive aggressive families
house
shriekston the American people
of course it's not about the American
people it's definitely not about quote
facts facts no it's about how Don Lemon
feels about himself
CNN president Chris Licht really ought
to sit down with this guy over a few
mango white Claws and just let him know
that just because somebody else is
pretty doesn't mean that you're ugly
it's okay Don you're beautiful inside or
something is it gonna work we don't know
but they got to try something Don Lemon
is on the brink
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight